he's to wean after day night me and the  boy returned his mother she died my son  has not spoken since he saw terrible  things he heard terrible things  hello Jacob  my name is Brenna and I'm going to be  staying here for a while I promise I'm  not like the others and much worse  you've come to make the boy talk just to  help if again give me your hands they're  strong like us  I assume it's his mother he hears or  thinks he hears you don't believe in  such boys no Senora I do not  Jacob doesn't want to hear he hasn't  shown yet but he will  Jacob yeah yeah  [Music]  was as you saw last night  you came danger to himself and to others  daga good boy  is all that matters the voice is real I  must know  laverna she's given me her elephants  I want to go now  [Music]